so the man of the hour is old dirty
bastard from wu-tang clan if you watch
the Grammys last night he just he just
stormed up right on stage he just
bogarted that mic he just took the mic
away from shawn colvin nobody tells him
what to do and he just bought new
clothes and everything but he explained
that okay old dirty bastard how are you
man
Hollister how long what's happening man
I just will let you know anybody in the
world you are very very very very very
unique real thank you I like that you
find me unique and I was thinking just
the same thing about you you look
exhausted like like last night was
completely out of control a little rest
but um it's fun and it's beautiful was
dirty and that's the way it is let me go
through it with you if you don't mind
mr. bastard may I call you mr. bastard
1010 wins was called a mr. bastard what
age did you become old dirty bastard
what was that your name at birth no his
name at birth is Russell Jones yes
Russell Jones is Russell Jones dead no
no no Russell Jones is here yeah he's in
the house yes definitely in the house
all right laughing well so whoo tang
clan mm has been together how many years
we've been together all our lives all
your lives so you went to the Grammys
because you were nominated but you were
nominated for what for the non-televised
Awards you know that they have a whole
bunch of awards that never get on TV
most of these words are not given out on
television so you bought a whole bunch
of new clothes and everything yes and
you went to the non-televised Awards and
you lost yes yes so who Puff Daddy yes
yes what was your category best album of
the year we lost uh Puff Daddy you know
and rap right now as you said puff
daddy's okay but would hang whoo tang is
number one yes yes because you guys rep
you you speak to the children is that
what you said
seriously explain that well it wasn't no
disrespect to puffy Hong Kong no hey you
know what it's not a war you felt hey
man we've been slighted man I mean you
know what's his puff daddy winning this
award and we weren't even televised mmm
I wasn't that it wasn't like that it was
just you know I'm telling my rap in
itself being televised you know what I
mean right right all of us as one being
televised you were disrespected yeah did
you decide early on that you were going
to run up on stage and interrupt Shawn
Colvin or did you did you did you just
happen to all of a sudden yes
just all of a sudden was happened and it
was there it was burning inside of you
yes you were
I don't know I just happen and I mean
like I said no disrespect to puffy you
know you got it going on you know I mean
yeah we you mean yes anyone who's
selling records I mean doing it doing
doing you know what they supposed to do
far as you know entertainment right you
know what I mean I know what you mean
that's beautiful right none of me right
I don't you just I feel that rap is here
you know and rappers gonna be here and
you know we felt that rap wasn't
represented right right so okay so wait
a second you see Erykah Badu announced
that award right right
and the next thing I see is you kissing
her on the cheek right oh that was she
wasn't showing you Shawn Colvin I didn't
know that so what did you do sprung out
you just sprung out of your chair and
you said I'm going up and I'm gonna say
something yes but I didn't know somebody
else had just gotten an award I didn't
know what type of water just you know I
didn't I just you just grabbed the money
yes yeah did you feel hey man maybe I
shouldn't be doing this or you don't
care um I felt both at the same time but
you know right you had to do what you
had to do late you just kept moving you
know all right you see a beautiful woman
keep moving and you got a big don't walk
sign in your face let's play let's play
for everybody what happened you walk
right up and while she was supposed to
be accepting her award you beat her to
the punch and you got up there let's
play your comments
please fall down I like that you told
the audience to calm down did you think
that they needed to be calm down why did
you tell him to calm down because I had
to calm down myself right you couldn't
believe what was going on alright let's
let's see what happen obviously you were
gripped by the moment what are you
teaching the children what are you
talking about right there
you're shaking your head you know as he
gets to the wu-tang is number one
there's a guy at his shoulder trying to
drag now were you gonna fight that guy
no no when he started dragging you off
did you realize it might have been more
serious than ever yeah people get upset
about that but I like the energy there I
understand what you're trying to do now
after this happens do they throw you out
of the Grammys or did they kick you out
backstage what happens as a result of
those did you run backstage and swipe
somebody's Grammy and run out with it no
no all right were people giving you a
cold shoulder not at all really
no no people were friendly to you did
they take you to the press yes yes they
did and let me ask you drunk or high on
pot or something when you did this oh no
I'm always sober right you've been sober
now for how long for how long Wow
what was that like six months yeah is
that really true I was warned your words
oh really
I see last night when man have it I say
whoa is he high really whoo well no
I only just water that's the only thing
I do so now you had to be all shook up
after what you did right yeah yeah the
Puff Daddy come up to you and say
anything bad or hey man what's up
so his bodyguards approached me yeah
yeah yeah they approached me like the
lights like like the Mafia son what they
say to you that I said look I mean no
you know no harm
ain't as a matter of fact by you
approach to me you know I mean I didn't
figure that you take it that way because
I mean I didn't mean nothing to probably
puppies not that much communication
going on but it's like it's like you
know you know I got love for puffy you
know I'm saying I hear you you know say
I mean ever since I knew puffy you know
saying I've been bobbing my head were
you saying man when you got up on stage
you said I don't see I don't know how
you see it well well I think whoo tang
is number one so you were basically
saying you thought root Ang's you two
won that award yes yes definitely yeah
because they help the kids let me get it
straight all right they all right
finally puffy is here for the kids too
you know what I mean I you know I you
know sometimes we say things out of
emotions you know and I'm not gonna lie
you know I love puffy you know and then
I love walk clap you know I love all rap
artists is you know I'm saying I hear
you you know
let's see what Aang tange exactly